we skipped a lot but i did this was like
the original weight loss so that says
this is not even as big as i got
i was even bigger than that and how much
did you weigh there this was like maybe
270. so i got 30 pounds heavier than
that wow damn
so so you legit hit 300. well i didn't
even know i was fat
what nobody told me you do that yes that
enabled it yeah insane
say my girl no you look good you're
looking like oh yeah cause you're tall
i'm like yes hey but my knees
don't don't agree my joints are hurting
right now
i can't drive my shoe [ __ ] like i was
really big man oh
i saw that picture too yep that one
right there oh damn so you know you know
who actually got me to lose weight was
actually
uh a specific joe rogan podcast it was
with david goggins
do you see what he does to you yeah
david goggins and there was another one
with
uh dr rhonda patrick okay so listening
to those podcasts kind of pieced
together
uh like i didn't realize how out of
shape i was because like health wasn't
an issue for me like when you're younger
it doesn't matter how fat you are still
playing ball i'm still doing whatever
yeah you know i just had like a one inch
vert but it didn't really matter
but i i didn't realize how out of shape
i was and there was literally this
moment and
it's just facts like my my fiance and i
went out to eat
and i'm i didn't know how big i was to
the point where i would sit there and
judge
fat people who are less fat than i would
preach you know what i mean this is my
life and so i was sitting here and i kid
you not this was the aha moment when we
went out to eat
there was a couple two fat fat people
but they're still not as fat as i am
yeah and i looked at them i was like
babe look at these [ __ ] fat people
and she looked at me she goes you're
fatter than them
i'm like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah thank
god you're talking like that's what
you're talking about
all right joke over with it what do you
mean she was like you're fat in them i'm
not fatter than them
yeah and i was like no [ __ ] way and
then i went on the scale and i was like
yo this scale's busted you know i
thought the same thing so like i'm
always making these excuses
about how big i am and then um went to
play ball
yo this is actually [ __ ] funny like
yeah yeah so i used to hoop a lot before
i [ __ ] up my knees and my ankles and
then
i literally tried to do a i tried to
cross somebody up the ball moved but my
body did it
and i'm like oh you're a fat person you
can't even extend your
fat [ __ ] arm to grab the ball on the
other side yeah
and everything started like piecing
together and i'm like i'm really out of
shape i got a blood test i did this
whole body scan [ __ ] yeah and then you
could really see
the actual numbers of how out of shape
doctor's like yeah you're fat man
it's confirmed so whatever you want
people to do we got to hear it though
yeah dude i think fast shaming works but
that but that's not what
but that fascinated me to get me was i
was trying to shave my my ball fro
okay you know what i'm saying man i had
to lift up man
but it was tough and that's what did it
for me that's what [ __ ] me up yeah i
was like [ __ ] i can't even
i was like i've never had to do that i
couldn't like really and he speaks these
before and afters in this
brave bastard sent it to the group chat
and i was like oh man
what that guy do baby
dude he got lit up and i was like this
is what you
think about well you got to hear it yeah
it's great man
i'll tell you what else to get you in
shape is because we work at this gym
called zoo culture and
we're the ugliest bradley martin's yeah
yeah we're the ugliest dudes in there
we're
like today when he came in i went dude
look at these [ __ ] dude there
was these dudes like
it was pretty warm in there he and i are
fully clothed all right
i got a turtleneck and they were just
jacked
do we have to work out dude they were
filming uh one of their workout videos
and i like went by with a ball like hey
big [ __ ] out of the way you'll see me
making a pants almost oh god
i apologize hey dog you're in the way
you know
i like those uh those gems though
because everybody is
a big [ __ ]
that definitely you can get a working
workout in a lot faster because
everybody's on their grind
yes you know that's why that's why i
love it so like when people
are you know they look like me and [ __ ]
they they feel like they can't go you
should go to those gyms because you can
get your workout in a lot faster people
don't [ __ ] around in there they're not
on their [ __ ] phones no they're ready
to get their [ __ ] done
get the work in and get out it's like i
worked out with bradley martin yesterday
we both got there
we were chopping it up and he's like man
you want to hit a workout real quick
he's like what you doing
i'm down for whatever man i was like oh
my shoulders kind of [ __ ] up i want to
tell him
and then you know he's [ __ ] massive
he's well i don't know if you ever see
him he's weird he doesn't look human
he's way bigger than me
one of the best dudes i've ever met me
and him we're like uh [ __ ]
uh you know he's great dude so we're
working out and he grabs 120 pound
dumbbells i'm like what the [ __ ]
and then he's like here we should do a
quick eight yeah we haven't even got him
all right yeah quick
here we go and then just because i felt
the pressure i'm doing it with him
yeah we got done i was like oh my
shoulder so bad
he's like you good but i'm like dude
yeah you see that video he posted
yesterday bro did you see that what are
you wearing i
was i was with him yeah somewhere dude
he puts me on game on merch because he's
like dude your merch you post stagnant
[ __ ] and stuff like this and he's like
you're selling
we were comparing numbers he's like dude
you're selling this and your promotion
is shitty
he's like videos go such further he's
like like he did that a long time with
the girls he did the girls uh
he was like i did that a long time ago
and then he's like this is what i'm
gonna post
and look what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
bro
that's 450 pounds
[Music]
look at those guys he got good hands his
shoulders
he's in joggers by the way those are
jean joggers
megan the stallion knees damn when
you're that strong you don't even need
to know how to fight
you just got to be big and strong yeah
he was like dude we got he was like we
got to try this thing um
no doubt you wanna do it wednesday i'm
like i think i'm gone
no way i love it but you can beat his
ass though right for real though yeah
yeah yeah i moved i would never but yeah
[Laughter]
i would never do that but yeah how about
that when i get off stage at the lab
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son